[Música]
el gobierno de Perú declara el estado de
emergencia en los departamentos de ica y
Arequipa que se suman al de andahuaylas
esto al tiempo que las fuerzas armadas
tomarán el control de la red Vial
aeropuertos y centrales hidroeléctricas
entre otros puntos estratégicos en
respuesta a las violentas protestas que
ya dejan al menos seis fallecidos
ampliamos desde Lima
en Argentina la celebraciones no se
hicieron esperar tras la victoria de las
Celeste 3 a 0 ante Croacia en la primera
semifinal de Qatar 2022 el único equipo
latinoamericano logró el pase a la final
con acción de Leo Messi y un doblete de
Julián Álvarez
Sam backman free el fundador de la
plataforma de criptomonedas compareció
ante un tribunal de nasautra ser
detenido el lunes fue acusado
formalmente de ocho cargos entre ellos
fraude electrónico y lavado de dinero el
juez Consideró que hay riesgo de fuga y
le negó la Libertad bajo fianza
ampliamos en esta emisión
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano y del mundial de fútbol de
Qatar soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y es
un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en Perú
donde a la ya tensa situación se suma
que las fuerzas armadas tomarán el
control de la red Vial aeropuertos y
centrales hidroeléctricas entre otros
lugares considerados estratégicos esto
luego de que el nuevo gobierno declarara
el estado de emergencia en otros dos
departamentos que se suman A andahuaylas
además de lo anterior la justicia aprobó
el proceso contra el ex jefe de estado
Pedro Castillo por rebelión previamente
conversamos con Francisco Zacarías que
nos amplió las medidas que ha tomado y
las que se espera que tome el gobierno
de Dina boluarte
el ministro de defensa de este país
Alberto tarula acaba de anunciar que la
el gobierno de la presidenta Dina
boluarte ha declarado emergencia los
departamentos de Arequipa e ica por 30
días esta medida se va a sumar a lo ya
este dispuesto en las provincias de
Apurímac que entre ellos la provincia de
andahuaylas esta acción también va a ser
complementada con la protección a la red
Vial nacional que se está ya declarando
de emergencia en las siguientes horas
Eso es para proteger los bienes
nacionales además de las hidroeléctricas
aeropuertos y otras instalaciones en la
medida ha sido tomada de abruptamente
porque se ha anunciado que se está
evaluando declarar todo el territorio
peruano nacional en estado de emergencia
pero que eso citó esta situación es que
hace pocas horas uno sigue manifestantes
Se tomaron la planta de gas de camisea
en la región de cusco y el Gobierno ya
ha decidido tomar este las medidas y
están implementando protocolos para la
distribución de tropas del ejército para
llevar mayor control esta situación se
está desarrollando Porque desde el
congreso y otros sectores del país se
está criticando la inactividad del
gobierno de Dina boluarte que hasta el
momento según la defensoría del pueblo
ha ocasionado la muerte de seis personas
el presidente de México Andrés Manuel
López Obrador defendió al ex mandatario
peruano Pedro Castillo asegurando que no
debió haber sido removido de su cargo
sin embargo negó incurrir en injerencia
en los asuntos de esa nación el lunes
los gobiernos de México Colombia y
Argentina pidieron respeto a la
investidura de castillo
Ni para bien ni para mal
no existe en México
lo de reconocimiento
a ningún gobierno
extranjero
lo que plantea el convenio es que se
debe respetar la voluntad
del pueblo que lo eligió
reconocer que ganó democráticamente
y que este
no se le puede
destituir
ni podrán
el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
firmó la ley de reforma tributaria una
polémica normativa aprobada por el
congreso cuyas discusiones tomaron
alrededor de tres meses la ley Busca
recaudar alrededor de tres mil
novecientos millones de dólares durante
2023 con un enfoque en combatir la
evasión fiscal según el mandatario el
objetivo es priorizar la lucha contra el
hambre y la pobreza al tiempo que se
aumentará la inversión en educación
salud protección del medio ambiente y
transición energética
miles de argentinos se congregaron en
torno al célebre obelisco de Buenos
Aires donde cantaron y bailaron para
festejar la victoria de la albiceleste
tres a cero ante Croacia el martes lo
que les da el pase a la final del
mundial de fútbol Messi abrió el
marcador y luego Julián Álvarez completó
con un doblete esta final es la
oportunidad perfecta para que Lionel
Messi el Astro de la selección logra
alzar la copa en el que podría ser su
último mundial una final
sentimiento Mira cómo está eso es
impresionante es una alegría inmensa
para todos para todos los argentinos de
vivir esto es único dice la canción No
te lo puedo explicar porque no lo vas a
entender
esto es único la verdad que me tocó
vivir ahora con estas dos finales y muy
emocionado porque
sé lo que es estar no jugué
profesionalmente pero sé lo que se
estará dentro de una cancha y lo que se
siente y la verdad que me alegro mucho
por los chicos que se lo merecen Ni
Messi más que todo este miércoles se
jugará la segunda semifinal entre
Francia y Marruecos en este mundial de
fútbol los detalles de lo que se puede
esperar en este encuentro donde saldrá
el rival de Argentina con nuestro
enviado especial a Qatar Juan pupiales
Marruecos y Francia definen Quién va a
acompañar a Argentina en la final de
esta copa mundo con Francia la duda o
las dudas son las de Javier y las de
upamecano ambos enfermos al parecer por
la climatización que está muy presente
en este país por su parte de shami Hugo
Yogui seleccionador y capitán dele Blend
reconocieron que se van a encontrar con
Una atmósfera difícil dado el poderío y
el gran peso que tiene la afición
Marroquín por parte de combinado
africano wallet y el seleccionador de
los marroquíes dice que no sabe Cuántos
seleccionados tiene y dio a conocer que
no será hasta último momento cuando sepa
Con cuántos efectivos contará para este
Duelo la única certeza será
efectivamente que habrá una fuerte
presencia de la afición Marroquín la
federación francesa estima que habrá
aproximadamente unos 14.000 aficionados
de Los Leones del Atlas frente a unos
3000 del combinado galo en bahama se
llevó a la primera audiencia de Sam
backman free el fundador de la
plataforma de criptomoneda safetyex
declarada en bancarrota el joven de 30
años Fue detenido el lunes por petición
de las autoridades estadounidenses y el
martes fue imputado por ocho delitos
entre ellos fraude electrónico lavado de
dinero y violación de las leyes de
financiación de campañas políticas el
juez Consideró que existe un alto riesgo
de fuga por lo que le negó la
posibilidad de Libertad bajo fianza
Estados Unidos pidió su extradición pero
aún no se conoce cuando iniciaría ese
proceso Daniel hablando en periodista
económica de France 24 nos amplió sobre
el caso
la historia de X es corta pero muy
sustanciosa comienza en 2019 cuando fue
fundada por Sam bankman friet un joven
que hoy tiene 30 años y que veían en
Wall Street como un niño prodigio de las
monedas digitales en poco tiempo se
convertiría en la segunda plataforma de
intercambio de criptomonedas más grande
del mundo el punto de quiebre vino
cuando hace un par de meses ocurrió una
corrida bancaria que es cuando los
usuarios se retiran los depósitos en
masa de una empresa que comienza a dar
señales de problemas de liquidez si todo
salen al tiempo la llevan a la quiebra
fix Se declaró efectivamente en
bancarrota el 11 de noviembre y dejó
aproximadamente un millón de clientes
enfrentando pérdidas de miles de
millones de dólares en palabras del
nuevo ceo de la empresa John Ray se
trató simplemente de una malversación de
más de ocho mil millones de dólares a la
antigua o sea tomar dinero de otros y
usarlo para fines propios Como por
ejemplo la compra de lujosas propiedades
en Bahamas también para apuntalar a otra
de sus firmas llamada a la mida algunos
lo comparan con un esquema ponzi o
piramidal o sea captar dinero del
público y usarlo indebidamente incluso
hay quienes lo llaman minimator haciendo
referencia a Bernard quien es uno de los
grandes estafadores de la historia de
Wall Street al final lo que más les
interesa a los inversionistas es si van
a recuperar su dinero la cruda respuesta
la tuvo el nuevo TX Este martes en el
congreso nunca recuperaremos todos esos
activos fue lo que dijo este martes el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
firmó la ley recientemente aprobada por
el congreso que protege a nivel Federal
el matrimonio igualitario y el
matrimonio interracial la normativa es
considerada un verdadero triunfo en
materia de igualdad y así se pronunció
el mandatario durante la ceremonia de
rúbrica
una cosa es que la Corte Suprema emita
un juicio sobre un caso y otra cosa
completamente diferentes y
representantes elegidos por la gente
voten en el pleno del Congreso de los
Estados Unidos y digan en voz alta y
claramente El amor es amor lo correcto
es lo correcto la justicia es la
justicia estas son cosas fundamentales
que Estados Unidos considera importantes
fin del informativo volvemos en breve
[Música]